tout le monde a amené une photo moi par
exemple on a découvert qu'ils avaient le
l'équipe dans l'équipe sosie de michel
drucker
regardez quand il était jeune regardez
c'est qui ça mokhtari sourire ah oui
vraiment c'est pas la même évolution
physique et non ils ont ils sont pas du
tout ça bouchonne à la voix rauque tard
mais vrai alors benjamin castaldi c'est
quoi votre photo alors c'est une photo
de moi à la campagne parce que comme je
l'expliquais est une verve et j'étais
très proche de la nature des animaux je
suis un petit peu en petits paysans
d'accord
basée à ces notions regarder ces
millions oui et c'est vous ça ouais en
fait j'étais beau petit après jurés
comment moi j'étais moche et je
redeviens pas mal été jusqu'à l'avant
fin ça il a été très beau ça mignon la
saveur la production nous avait appelé
en début d'après midi pour demander de
photos honteuses de gros machin il
envoie la photo il est canon ouais ouais
mais bon des mois j'ai beau chercher je
ne suis jamais honteux ma photo je
voudrais montrer une photo de vous cyril
parce qu'elles étaient publiées dans
paris-match et je voulais souligner
parce qu'il voulait le ban encore non
non pas du tout a pour une fois non je
suis très mauvais c'était évidemment une
lignée de dieu
on a beaucoup rigolé avec talent
l'émission il adore et on adore la mer
c'est votre photo et bars et une photo
je me prend pour une star heger doit
avoir 10 11 ans cette voie doit ça fait
drôle ça c'est belaiba web et il y avait
un truc s'appelait sisters sa raquette
mais c'est aux états unis à des sommets
comment tu t'appelles avec halak la bnm
dont 110 111 ans avec tata tt 2 sortait
qu'un câble ou pas non mais onze ans à
tapis à clous avaient peut-être avoir un
petit amoureux non j'avais en amoureux
mais il se passait rien j'ai franchement
way allez vous oui bah c'est pas nous
arriver en moi c'est ma photo avec moi
je
[Applaudissements]
on n'a pas reçu le même mail de la
production suite et l'émission ici à 3 4
ont jamais eu comme gage de passer tout
le week-end dans la fin j'étais parti
j'ai des parties jusqu'à saint-etienne
habillée comme ça est ce que si je
m'étais endormi contre la vitre je
bavais et dont j'ai reçu plein de photos
après sur twitter de moi en train de
baver le laval refaire ça la pana ce
week-end à wissant par christine kelly
vous avez une photo de moi j'écoutais
d'introduction une photo en deux 2 mois
oui vous avez des photos alors meetic 60
afin un garçon voilà ce qui vous attend
très mal voiture non j'ai dit que
parfois on me dit que je ressemble un
garçon sur cette photo ja rondo 10 ans
j'ai toujours eu un peu les yeux un peu
aucun aucun aucun mot est peut-être un
mois toutes les photos sont honteuses
donc les prunes à l'école en ce2 où je
suis avec mes plus beaux habits
c'est tout la peau est folle bah oui
normalement cette mocheté commence
normalement tu les vois et après tu les
vois dans faites entrer l'accusé
on n'a pas la photo de super nes bébé en
stock ce qu'il avait lu le boeny regarde
la wii à bbc le soldat il ya quarante
deux ans déconner quoi c'est sa vraie
fausse droite mais qu'elles vont
travailler ce médecin très mental weiler
vénère très énervée dit tf1
oui c'est bien ça veut dire qu'il se
bonifie
il est pas mal 18 oui j'ai faites entrer
l'accusé l'horrible 21 hippie punk à
widou t il beau frère un petit côté
hugues aufray j'ai des demandes est très
bon oh la la c'est une faute
alors c'est quoi c'est non celle ci
estime me rappelle qu'on est dans les
mêmes eaux brigitte et moi donc si vous
êtes grossièrement vous êtes grossier
avec l'alcool la vitesse juste vous êtes
très belle c'est ma première photo
d'identité est la seule au contraire où
j'étais pas hideuse que j'étais
tellement moche qu'on me faisait baisser
la tête pudiquement on ne voit pas le
moins possible et donc là c'est la seule
potable où j'étais moi j'ai autorisé
mois que j'ai vu quand j'étais petit
c'était qu'elle a déjà dit ok venir
windows est doué c'est quoi ces cinq ans
métier c'est de charité c'est ça mais
content et ça sort fait aux matons où
c'était chiant photographie chez un
photographe avec votre actu en
maintenant c'est tout ça oui oui c'est
ma maison ma soeur et dont on dispose
ici c'est l'avion parce que la grève
était en fait quand belle bouffée mets
préparés comme ça allait mais qu'il est
averti que vous avez perdu très belle là
c'était le seul mois où j'avais grossi
j'étais passé à savoir combien vous
étiez passé contre 55 kg alors que je
fais car on a bien fait ça très bien la
fin au feuilleton dallas par hp 49 50
noms seront choyés vraiment vous saviez
vous mettre sur une balance à 149,50
était malade oui j'adore passer mon
délire s'il passe où manquent les meufs
sur mon délire mais là ça saigne de moi
j'adore les femmes comme ça hein alors
les granola
mais mieux quelque chose at et pépito
des canadairs faire bouffer grenoble
vous a échappé belle ou alors elle à mon
coeur je n'ai deux mois donc une demande
de temps déjà pas bon coeur sinon j'ai
mon l'artichaut parce que j'aime bien on
effeuille quelques euros sans l'accord
de ses jolies alors je n'ai de une deux
mois parce qu'elles chauffent qu'elle
représente bien ce que je suis c'est à
dire à la fois le bien-être l'entretien
de soi et la culture dont je peux vous
la montrer booking de provinces et plus
ou 7 mai et tu es bien masquer ses
malheurs oui c'est intéressant de
préciser au squash optimale
alors c'est ça masque concombre et
brocolis non reconnu ces cow-boys
encombre non mais
et ça tombe bien on fait beaucoup rire
sextos liant et après le concombre
recenseur ou perdre autant oui la peau
ce retard nous ça hop ouais ouais il
faut le mettre enfin si vous êtes très
drôle sur coup et puis le bouquin je
pense que je relisais adobuzz qui entame
sa paie un peu ces le menu bleu il est
en train de commander une eau mais qui
me fait croire à un destin et 6 à
l'horaire non mais thomas également cet
escroc un fraudeur et jeanine de toi mon
coeur dans adobe qui on va dire amen une
pièce de plus au peuple si je peux me
permettre
pour ceux qui avaient encore quelques
doutes regardez là voilà voilà
[Rires]
parce que ça moi je m'en fous je juge
rien mais quand tu vas connaître toutes
les chansons de mylène farmer qu'on
déguise en fille et pour les williams
chez vous syrie menacer pour la grosse
émission son jeu pacman pas d'embrasser
bon enlever la pac mal à l'aise quand tu
paies pas du tout mal posez vous les
bonnes questions
bon bah non c'est un même toit les
bonnes réponses surtout maintenant il ya
un moment où ça va assez bon oui j'aime
mylène farmer oui
ayala et hervé vilard way est un village
where he et quoi bas et merci à gâteau
coup et larusso et mariah carey est donc
oui mariah carey non merci à toi oui
mais moi j'avais envoyé une photo de moi
bébé où j'étais très mignonne et on m'a
dit non il faut vraiment un truc où tu
es ridicule et un truc qu'on te d'un
coup j'ai envoyé une photo je suis des
glaces au vous avez fait toute votre
instinct non j'ai rien ne sort que des
cg golasa mais pas du tout j'avais les
cheveux très longs et ce qui est très
gênant c'est que je vois pas une goutte
d'alcool donc jamais été libre de ma vie
est là on dirait que je suis chez
alcoolisées par contre comme toulouse de
voir l'accueil derrière la le gala frère
si les pende enquête policière
le gaia weiss échauffourées là dans le
jeu me fait pas trop pousser les cheveux
non alors on en a rien à [ __ ]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup à l'egypte
siri vous faites des points cam et riou
quelle mauvaise foi non mais vous
contrôlez tous il faut laisser pousser
au caa
on est d'accord moi parce que vous avez
fait un carré comme ça c'est des moments
mais trop court merci aussi à l'or
c'était en 1970 à l'époque là ma famille
on faisait pas de photos franchement
doter ce fonds est intégré dans notre
famille ne faisait pas de photos ces
trois qui siècle et tout pourquoi tous
trop moche et en fait on a que des on
n'a que des photos événementiel et la
sophie ciel non mais c'est vrai quoi
c'est la première fois que vous avez
ouvert votre point soleil mais elle date
j'avais 11 ans et c'était ma première
communion
alors je revois cette neige terry parce
qu'en fait elle va t en fait vous voyez
plus ton zen avant des années on dirait
une boussens dirait qu'ils pointent vers
le bas
mais si new delhi n'ont hélas millions -
non non non et là la messe ce qu'il y
avait à la télé mais les sébastien et il
avait mais chez je voulais faire pareil
ça accord maintenant brasse est passé
sur mon choix j'ai un nom compliqué chez
vous et vous oui moi à l'époque j'ai
adoré passer du toit en toile est tous
cas contraire devrait passer du temps
aux toilettes pas me dois aussi on
connaît l'état une fois en restera là
facile des milliards aux toilettes
l'un des jabots chinois
comment casser les jolies filles c'est
rien ça arrive à tout le monde même aux
meilleurs oui et bien étrange jeune
aussi voilà quoi c'était une photo de
toi toi et fais mais il était déjà très
cultivé c'est quoi comme violent c'était
un bouquin de culture générale non mais
seriez parce que l'attitude et un
bouquin sur un petit retard et de la
gela s'appellerait pousse à tout le
bouquin bon c'est vrai il est resté à 15
ans est en tout cas très belles photos
elle a toujours était mignonne a été
moins blonde
ouais c'est vrai mr sahraouis et là
c'est le coloriste qui parle